[Musique]
c'est
goldorac le
grand Goldor goldorac Astro Boy
capitaine flamme en passant par Albator
c'est la plus grande collection
française de robots japonais des années
70 80 celui qui en est à l'origine c'est
lui Baptiste cillot pendant 25 ans il a
collectionné près de 300 robots japonais
mais aussi leur boîte d'origine pour la
première fois il expose toutes ses
pièces à l'espace richau de Versailles
jusqu'au 25 février 2024 nous on a on a
découvert la cette cette culture
japonaise du manga et de l'animé avec
goldorac encore une fois cette culture
qui était tellement loin de la nôtre
avec ces ces ces robots géants pilotés
par par des êtres humains des jeunes
gens c'est la première fois que les
enfants se sentaient aussi touchés par
un dessin animé première fois avec ses
couleurs vives c'estes ceses ses héros
surdimensionnés encore une fois qui
échappé totalement notre imaginaire et
en fait ils ont compris qu'ils allaient
pouvoir par leur culture influencer
énormément une culture européenne et
c'est à partir de là qui'est né le soft
power japonais ces robots ne sont plus
de simples jouets ils sont devenus de
véritables produits marketing témoignant
l'influence culturelle du Japon à
l'international c'est la première fois
qu'en France en fait on avait des
dessins animés avec autant de produits
dérivés autour donc Goldor qui était
dans sa sououscoupe il était sur des
mugs sur dans des autocollants sur des
cartes Panini des t-shirts en fait il y
avait un marchandising gigantesque des
vinyes tout ça et c'est la première fois
nous français qu'on découvrait ça si
l'exposition met notamment l'accent sur
l'iconique goldorac les visiteurs
pourront aussi découvrir d'autres pièces
uniques fabriqué par des manufacture
japonaise plus confidentielle certains
robots n'ont jamais été montrés en
[Musique]
France de lumière et
d'acier ce chevalier